we literally sat back and watched him
not want to hold a Jersey not wanna put
the head on you go there you're on there
hey daddy I'm gonna get you down there
the flabby Brady Brady Brady hello and
welcome everybody to Gillette Stadium in
Foxborough Massachusetts the locker
rooms are bugged the sidelines are being
recorded
it's cheater Ville 2018 I'm Jets Homer
Adam Lefko joined as always by Patriots
fan boy Christopher says that's right
the AFC East champs 14 out of the last
15 years there slugger when's the last
time you want it that who cares the AFC
least is what you are Moe Lewis knocked
out drew bledsoe in comes Tom Brady
you're welcome Belichick learned from
Parcells you're welcome
don't say you want grilled your
franchise Belichick didn't want to work
for you guys 24 hours and he had enough
there and hey thanks for Darrelle Revis
too we want a Super Bowl with him
appreciate that you're kind of like our
farm team your triple a system for us
New England Patriots oh speaking of
being on the farm out to pasture Tom
Brady almost time for him to be forced
to retire with the way he's playing
don't know about it my California
quarterback is young and still has
muscle definition Oh kind of
embarrassing when you're losing to a 41
year old quarterback once again mmm all
I know is we have more Pro Bowlers than
you oh and a stop-start living off that
Joe Namath they're a little longer 1960
yahwah who cares that was forever ago
close the yearbook and try to win
something recent there's only one thing
we can agree what's that why the hell
did Tom Brady kiss his kid that long
because he's the goat and he wait you
approve of this kid he's the dope the
greatest dad of all time deal with it
Brady Brady Brady Brady Brady Brady
Brady his rookie year I knew he's a
baller because he was letting our
sideline know how much money yeah no
thanks already he was letting us know he
was the man cuz he's top ten pick right
would you go eight yeah woody I was
traffic yeah that's my only here the
draft draft was amazing man yeah two
thousand four thousand four and that was
back with
you know they only took about to the top
five guys you know I'm in the room with
guys like Eli Manning who's supposed to
be number one overall Big Ben and Robin
gallery and I'm like dude I don't care
if I [ __ ] in that green room and I'm the
last one I want to share in this
experience and you know we had a running
joke like who's gonna be the last guy
drafted and you know I wouldn't upset I
said I'm gonna be the last one I know
I'm going to tan to Houston so everyone
kind of has their own table when you
haven't been drafted you're sitting back
watching this unfold right and so yeah
we Eli San Diego draft Sims before they
actually figure out the tree we
literally sat back and watched him not
want to hold the Jersey not wanna put
the head on he's just in there is and so
as the drafts kind of going on guys are
getting called guys are getting called
me and Ben or less and I'm just thinking
you know and I had actually went to the
bathroom and then I hear my name eight
and you know as I'm hugging my mom and
kissing her and dapping up my brothers
and stuff I just kind of look over in
bed and like I guess you'll a running
joke that's awesome he probably went in
the best spot because he has two rings
he went to a great defense great
organization and so everything happens
for a reason but I was not the last one
even though all week long that's all we
joked about so DeAngelo Hall got to
point at Big Ben and go guess you laugh
yeah and Big Ben totally went to the
perfect situation well I mean gosh I
mean guess you last in the top 12 isn't
that that demeaning like believe well
guess your last you have to get picked
in the top ten I remember
Eli Phillip and Ben being drafted and it
was an amazing preacher F debate you
would this guy from North Carolina state
with a weird release angle right who had
Archie's other son and Eli yeah and you
would Big Ben yeah coming from the mat
right ready to tear it up right as we
look at their careers yeah how do you
stack them up now to me Ben
Roethlisberger is the best one of the
bunch I mean Ben Roethlisberger I think
is a truly great talent I think he's
borderline top ten quarterback of all
time he was a little bit like
indefensible at times because he had
that ability to
scramble around the pocket all the years
we sold Big Ben with a defender on him
and still being like you know what no
but still thought he already Yard
exactly right he's a great down the
field thrower he could play in any
offense so I do look at him as being the
best one on the field
Philip was the best self OC Wow Philip
is the you go there you're on there hey
you dadgum anova get you down there in
the flat but without any of the most
kids let the coach write it looks like
yeah Philip so like a must-watch yeah
when you see him on the field and the
few times I got to play against him or
at least be on the sidelines and watch
him yeah the fire from him you can feel
it on the field yes it's all three are
awesome all three are gonna be in the
Hall of Fame or say about you life you
know I had two great playoff runs and
two great Super Bowl performances I
would say is regular-season career
you're part of our average and your
heart apart I'm gonna put you on the
spot like ogre right whoa is my Jason
Witten is I don't know
is Eli hall-of-famer in your heart in my
heart no Eli is not a hall-of-famer
but he's really gonna make wave so
listen I'm not trying to hate on Eli
Manning I know I agree my dad's Phil
Simms and don't make this razorback the
Giants history I got that I don't care I
do not think Eli Manning is all a favor
I think he's an all-time great you know
how the Hall of Fame he does pass my one
Hall of Fame rule though but can you
tell the story the NFL without him and I
don't think you can then yeah well
problem because of those two because of
the two Super Bowls yeah I hear you you
know what sir yeah Jim Parkin won two
Super Bowls he's not in the Hall of Fame
all I ask is the Manning family please
don't have us hurt like please I think
instead I hit manatees like you guys are
great seriously all right baby let's
finish this season strong you know which
new stand we're going to final pick of
the regular season
Aly be that Oracle it is not about the
destination it is about the journey but
our current destination the final
regular-season games somebody in left go
Vick Cowboys had to New York to take on
the Giants and I wore this nice shirt
for you what is this velvet yeah man no
it might actually be very expensive I
feel like you're not a big Cowboys fan
not at all no not at all hate that's
what I'm feeling
wow I don't like the word but when it
comes to the Cowboys and the Eagles the
same thing just unnecessary dig from
this guy
Giants they're fighting for pride
they're fighting for Shermer second year
I suppose yeah what do you think I hate
to say it you're going Cowboys gotcha
you don't think Eli is gonna go out
there and make a few guys miss maybe a
break a tackle
I think Ezekiel amoebic you guys missed
before Eli alright so Cowboys yes now
other season yes sir hopefully I see you
next year yeah or maybe let me produce
the ship Ali went against his fandom
he's taking the Cowboys in no loyalty
and that guy I'll tell you I mean just
he'll just throw his team away don't
worry though we do a great yeah I mean
Dallas was playing for something they
want to get into the playoffs on the
right foot I'm more interested in the
quarterback situations for next season
right I know the Cowboys still have some
playoffs ahead of them but the cowboy
situation with dak yeah you have a
number in your head because he's gonna
be a free agent that you just can't pay
him more if you want this team to
continue to grow right well he's not
gonna be a free agent but he's eligible
to get the new contract right gotcha
so then they had they're gonna give it
to I would imagine yes but yours is
around like the 1820s the Andy Dalton's
the Matt not the matched efforts anymore
but somewhere in there yeah yes the the
the high teens low 20s it they they
should not let him hold them hostage for
28 million dollars a year Matt Ryan
Aaron Rodgers tight money no way
negative Ghost Rider because if you give
them that money it takes away that that
nickel corner it takes away that backup
tight people on your roster the problem
though is if you look around the league
yeah what are the best options you've
come out the best options and they're
not bad I just don't think Cowboys fans
would be happy
I would agree they're not going to
excite people and hey listen
some things could also happen that I
don't foresee I mean will Ryan Tannehill
definitely be in Miami interest I don't
know but who were the names all right
Joe Flacco let's for one we know he's
gonna be on the outs in Baltimore I know
I hear you but he did with a Super Bowl
and I still think you can win with him
Teddy Bridgewater okay people get very
excited by Teddy they definitely do
Andy Dalton could be on the outs not
gonna sell them you're not gonna sell
them no Cowboys fans are you know I want
dak back okay and then what about a
Jameis Winston they they're gonna mmm
that's a tough one no it's more his
talent can it excite you though his
talent can excite you now but I hear you
okay so so that that's fine I'm curious
about Eli though yeah because now we're
at a situation where it seems like they
want to go into 2019 is there another
option there i as an Eagles fan hope
they go into 2019 with Eli whether they
bring them back or not they need to
draft a quarterback whether that's to
sit behind you live a year or to be the
guy we know rookie quarterbacks can go
to the playoffs we've seen it Joe Flacco
did it
Russell Wilson did it oh wait dak
Prescott the guy we were just talking
about his rookie year they were the
number one seed in the NFC so it's not
were the Giants that start alive forever
stops talking mainly about worsen seats
at home I am the lef koe Eagles fan
that's a holla holla holla at you later
enjoy the games we have this young
quarterback from California right you
might get some youth in that line I
don't know that guy seems a little
immature he dressed up as Santa Claus on
some stupid show last week that's really
yeah yeah Sims and left go never heard
how to get you anyway Bill Parcells
taught Bill Belichick you're welcome we
built your French well I mean Parcells
didn't want got it yeah peace bro hey
what's up homies thanks for watching
subscribe to the be our YouTube channel
man you're such a millennial also while
you're here we have a lot of other
videos check them out and then what time
does our show come out Wednesday 8:00
p.m. be there or be square
he ruined it it was really close